[Musique]
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 politique sur tv fils chaque
mercredi une nouvelle édition pour
suivre au mieux la campagne des
législatives dans le département
yvelinois aujourd'hui deux invités dans
un instant le candidat de la france
insoumise dans la première
circonscription thibault marshall et
puis déjà en plateau mathilde andraud et
bonjour je vous êtes candidate du front
national dans la 11e circonscription
peut-être un mot tout d'abord sur la
composition du gouvernement au moment où
nous enregistrons cette émission la
composition était tout juste dévoilée
gérard collomb à l'intérieur nicolas
hulot ministre d'état à la transition
écologique françois bayrou garde des
sceaux bruno le maire -ministre de
l'économie ou encore laura flessel pour
le sport que vous inspire cette
composition du gouvernement
alors si la france n'était pas dans
l'état dans lequel il était on pourrait
rire parce que bon on prend les mêmes et
on recommence tout simplement donc pour
le redoux pour le renouveau il faudra
revenir mon avis gistau l'agglo n'avait
pas été ministre jusqu'à présent par
exemple non mais où nicolas hulot fait
partie des tablettes de multiples et
multiples personnes dans le dallas en
politique depuis des années donc voilà
pour vous rien de nouveau on en rien
nouveau hélas pour les français surtout
mon envie aux législatives vous allez
défendre les couleurs de marine le pen
dans la 11e circonscription
circonscription qui n'a pas été
forcément très favorable au front
national sur les communes qui les plus
importantes qui la composent si on
regarde les résultats pour les pour la
présidentielle on peut revoir le score
sur elancourt par exemple un peu plus de
20% sur trappe également tout petit peu
moins de 20% ce que vous êtes inquiète à
l'approché du scrutin législatif sur
cette circonscription la 11e aucunement
parce que l'actuel gouvernement de lier
le prouve c'est que face à mâcon qu'à
l'opposition il bat il reste les
patriotes
il nous reste il reste nous en fait tout
simplement le front national donc je
pense que crée cette alternative est
justement enrayer un peu la logique qui
va être lancée par macro qui une logique
de continuation du continuité voilà je
me rends contraire je suis
je trouve ce challenge très revigorant
lorsque vous avez vu les résultats de la
présidentielle sur votre circonscription
celle où vous vous présentez pas 10 ça
va être quand même très compliqué mais
tout est compliqué mais bon ce matin en
2011 le front national sur la 11e
circonscription avait terminé au premier
tour avec -2 9% et est même en 2002
quand jean-marie le pen avait réussi à
accéder au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle peu près le même score 8
72% certain plafond au moment des
législatives autour de 10%
oui mais en même temps si on s'arrêtait
juste au passé on ne donnait pas plus
d'efforts ben on en serait bien ce
serait jamais même à rêver au premier
tour la des présidents tels donc en
l'occurrence non ces voix là il faut
s'il faut s'atteler il faut aller faire
du terrain faut aller parler aux
français allait défendre la france parce
que je pense que c'est un enjeu
essentiel dans ces législatives
donc non c'est d'ailleurs vouloir dit
quoi aux électeurs justement vous allez
porter qu'est ce qui va changer dans le
programme on est dans la continuité du
programme qui a été porté pendant la
campagne présidentielle des ajustements
non on est là on va dans la continuité
en l'occurrence il s'agit de faire une
opposition à cette alliance qui est
caché derrière macron info renouveau
cette alliance des républicains d'un ps
repassé à la machine à laver aussi donc
mais en l'occurrence là encore on
retrouve les mêmes les mêmes têtes les
mêmes logiques et donc
ce qu'il faut dire aux français c'est ne
leur laissait pas non plus le un
boulevard pour aller casser le code du
travail pour laisser rentrer encore de
millions d'immigrés pour la défendre
notre identité défendre notre
souveraineté économique et font de la
liberté
voilà il faut une véritable opposition
en france et en l'occurrence
l'opposition est incarnée par nous sur
les points de programme précis votre
campagne sur la 11e circonscription
parce qu'il faut même si c'est un
scrutin national et qu'il faut aller
représenter ensuite ensuite à à
l'assemblée à l'assemblée nationale avec
tous les autres députés il faut se faire
élire sur une circonscription il faut
lui coller à la réalité du terrain la
réalité du terrain dans la 11e
circonscription
cette session hélas parfois s'illustre
nationalement avec des thèmes sur la
lutte contre le communautarisme je pense
qu'on est au coeur du sujet dans la 11e
circonscription en train des politiques
locales qui sont ouvertement
clientéliste qui encourage le
communautarisme et des effets totalement
pervers et voir mortifère on voit des
jeunes partir enfin trappe c'est quand
même illustré par un départ de
cinquantaine de personnes en syrie voilà
qu'est ce qu'on fait contre ça et je
pense que ça c'est des mesures
nationales et donc le local en
l'occurrence ici chez nous fait écho à
des problèmes qui touchent toute la
france c'est nous les français on
continue à évoquer vos différentes
propositions pour cette campagne
législative juste une petite pause pour
évoquer une situation précise celle des
travailleurs dans le bâtiment travaux
publics la fédération des bâtiments et
travaux publics dans les yvelines
organise cette semaine une rencontre
avec des représentants politiques dans
le département pour présenter alors 112
propositions pour ces législatives et
nous avons donnée justement la parole à
cette profession écouter on appelle
fabrice martinez chez 51 ans j'habite à
voisins le bretonneux et je travaille
dans l'entreprise locale de saint-vaast
50 un bâtiment et je suis chef d'equipe
on travaille huit heures par jour
et ont fait 39 heures dans la semaine
mon salaire c'est 2
2000 euros par mois l'heure pour les
présidentielles j'ai voté la france
insoumise qui me correspondent beaucoup
plus dans mes idées et pour les
législatives
je ferai de même pour ce qui est juste
hâtives sur une attente qu'on parle
d'eux
des retraites
les pouvoirs d'achat et des salaires et
au niveau des impôts nous paye
énormément de taxes ce qui fait que le
salaire augmente quasiment pas le
pouvoir d'achat est assez réduit depuis
plusieurs années moi je suis plus en
attente sur
la france insoumise qui propose des
choses
du coup une crête la flexibilité apporte
des petits boulots et peu payée avec une
amplitude horaire extrêmement large
ce qui fait que après la vie privée il
reste plus beaucoup d'heures à passer au
conte soyez mais ça c'est très
franchement très mauvais on a entendu
parler des retraites du pouvoir d'achat
des salaires aussi également alors ça
touche cette profession mais mais les
autres aussi quelles sont les
propositions que vous portez je trouve
cet exemple très parlant parce qu'en
l'occurrence aussi cette profession est
frappé de plein fouet par la directrice
des travailleurs détachés clairement le
bâtiment l'activité le bâtiment en
france a été presque digérer en fait pas
à cause de cette directive qui permet
d'employer des personnes à très bas coût
et donc évidemment à ne pas offrir
d'emplois en france dans le bâtiment
notamment
et concernant évidemment cette structure
qui est une petite structure on aura
tendance à lui rappeler qu'il a une
clause a totalement raison le nombre de
charges qui pèsent sur ces petites
structures qu'on est pas du tout alors
que les dernières aides même sous le
gouvernement macron en fait aidé les
grosses structures
et oui la raison la macro nidation de la
france et lui brisa sion de notre
économie de notre travail
donc ces petits boulots
esther juste aussi encore attirer les
conditions de travail à la baisse à
casser encore c'est toutes les
protections sociales qui avaient donc le
but je sais aussi d'ordre est de ne pas
casser ce code du travail tenait pas axe
de retirer la loi elle comme rite
clairement qui est va être adopté viard
ordonnance cet été voilà et donc oui il
ya plein de choses sur lesquelles on a
montré à savoir aussi baisser les impôts
et les charges qui peuvent s'adapter
d'entreprise faut savoir que le
gouvernement macro landes
c'est plus 32 milliards d'impôts donc en
france donc voilà il faut sortir de là
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
pense qu'il faut aussi bloqué le l'élan
l'élan de la marche qui est en mars et
aujourd'hui quel est l'objectif pour le
front national c'est d'obtenir une force
d'opposition et de d'influencer le
gouvernement ou de réussir à 2 va
obtenir une majorité et pourquoi pas une
cohabitation
bien évidemment le but du jeu est arrivé
à malades à l'arrivée le bouc ou le plus
loin possible pour défendre les intérêts
des français parce qu'en l'occurrence on
voit monsieur macron 13 omnubilé par
l'intérêt de l'europe pensait européen
organisé un gouvernement économique
européen c'est dans ses tablettes
sauf que voilà en l'occurrence ce
monsieur dans le bâtiment est clairement
une victime de cette europe qui a pour
seul credo la concurrence à tout prix et
même au prix bas d'une vie normale une
vie près de sa famille comme une audi et
une vie digne avec un salaire digne
j'aimerais qu'on prenne quelques
instants à présent pour vous présenter
au delà des propositions ou êtes conseil
régional c'est la première fois vous
vous présentez dans cette 11e
circonscription des yvelines vous aviez
participé à un scrutin municipal des
emplois dans le département c'était du
côté de huy également sur le candidate
pour les départementales pourquoi la 11e
circonscription pourquoi ce changement
de localisation
je pense l'immense symbolique d'arrivée
cinq circonscriptions où en étant une
femme une femme et lui une femme dans la
vie active une femme dans la vie
publique montré que les femmes ont toute
leur place et je trouve que dans la
circonscription que se trouve trappe
c'était hautement symbolique c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai demandé cette
circonscription c'est vous qui l'avez
demandé mais on l'a accepté
c'est une circonscription difficile le
maire les républicains des longs cours
soit retrouvé son poste il est
aujourd'hui vice-président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et puis c'est aussi la
circonscription d'un ancien candidat à
l'élection présidentielle benoît hamon
ça ne vous effraie pas non aucunement
with it came la place par le front
national
voilà une fois pour les femmes en
politique bon il ya une place pour les
français parce que je pense qu'on est
même meilleur porte parole des français
de leur intérêt votre adversaire
principal
benoît hamon jean michel fourgous
d'autres formations politiques
la france est soumise qu'à ceux qui
s'entêtent à coeur de renouer qui a
priori se retrouve tout son gouvernement
peu importe les couleurs d'origine a
remis sur un accord éventuel ou non avec
debout la france avec le mouvement de
nicolas dupont aignan pas d'accord alors
pas d'accord au premier tour en effet ça
a été entendu prouvant bien par là que
nous ne rentrons pas dans
ces calculs qui a pu avoir entre
monsieur bayrou et monsieur mac ronde en
ou non c'est peut-être d'avoir quelques
points pour participer pourquoi pas une
triangulaire sur le second tour
peut-être mais l'honnêteté veut que
voilà les français et un maximum de
choix je pense que la diversité en
politique c'est important mais en même
temps lors du second tour ont fait voilà
ces choix fondamentaux
on s'attend s'annonce accord sur
l'essentiel est donc
voilà on y réfléchira après le 11 juin
vous êtes vous êtes une jeune
représentante du front national n'est en
84 vous ai dit aussi auparavant au fnj
vous êtes proche du vice-président du
front national florian philippot
pourquoi avoir rejoint le front national
auparavant vous étiez aussi à terra nova
qui est un groupe de réflexion qui est
plus proche du parti socialiste
qu'est ce qu'il va voir votre
partagèrent à terra nova
rien de plus et ben l'occurrence c'est
vraiment mon quotidien c'est à dire que
voilà j'ai été élève boursière c'est
grâce à la république s'est adressé à la
france que j'ai pu faire mes études des
études qu'on qualifie plutôt de ba voila
de qualité à sciences po et ma vie
professionnelle en plus après m'a amené
à fréquenter après le milieu la
communication et mieux parisien et que
je trouve est totalement déconnecté en
fait de la réalité de la réalité que je
pouvais retrouver quand je retournais
chez moi en banlieue avec voilà d'une
une insécurité culturel grandissante
d'insécurité économique réelle voilà et
donc
le jour de mon anniversaire de mai 26
ans je me suis dit voilà j'ai joué à
rendre à la france qu'elle a réussi à
m'offrir à moi pour que tous les
français puissent bénéficier de la même
chose je crois vraiment l'ascenseur
social qui représentait les power peut
représenter l'école de la république et
donc c'est pour me je me bats en fait
pour ce voilà pour cette égalité
scolaire pour cette défense je suis
aussi très souvent des vies très
attachés à notre souveraineté
donc voilà je vous qui êtes une jeune
représentante du front national et ce
sera ma dernière question est ce que le
front national doit rentrer aussi dans
une phase de recomposition on a vu le
départ par exemple de marion maréchal-le
pen est ce que à l'issue des
législatives la la campagne est lancée
mais après le 18 juin il va falloir
aussi repenser le front national changer
de nom pourquoi pas la nuance sur le
départ de marion maréchal-le pen qui a
un départ de pour raisons personnelles
et nullement politique il n'empêche peut
être difficile à comme un pacte pour le
mouvement est bon pour l'image de
mouvement alors évidemment toutes
personnes talentueuses qui s'en va et ça
nous fait de la peine
mais en même temps mon c'est l'occasion
elle a été un excellent porte parole
pour la jeunesse justement cette
jeunesse qui monte en politique je pense
que voilà ça ouvre aussi la perspective
de nouvelles de l'arrivée de nouvelles
têtes de nouveaux
de nouveaux styles et s'il faut repenser
recomposées ou pas ce front national
venir le nom les arts etc c'est
l'orientation des lignes claires aussi
peut-être en se basant sur les résultats
de la présidentielle avec des résultats
qui ont été finalement un peu en dessous
de ce qui pouvait être attendu par la
formation
oui en même temps je du seul contre tous
je trouve qu'on se débrouille pas trop
mal avec plus de 10 millions d'électeurs
second tour mais évidemment c'est une
grande réflexion de fond sur comment
aussi
apaiser notre image leur montrer qu'on
est vraiment les meilleurs avocats des
français et donc c'est tout un travail
en effet qui peut se faire et justement
là d'où l'intérêt de cette ce dialogue
avec debout la france mais encore
d'autres personnes qui sont sincèrement
patriotes et attachés aux libertés des
français
merci mathilde andrew et je rappelle que
vous êtes candidate dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines face à vous
notamment le parti communiste avec luc
miserait ou encore le député socialiste
sortant benoît hamon la france a un
soumise avec si les reader ou encore
nadia et pour la république en marche la
liste définitive sera connue d'ici au 19
mai dépôt en préfecture des candidatures
et qui se tient actuellement merci
merci' sommes le 7 8 politique se
poursuit nous allons évoquer la
situation dans la première
circonscription des yvelines à présent
dans un instant thibault marshall c'est
le candidat de la france insoumise et
voici déjà le représentant le portrait
de la représentante socialiste également
sur ce secteur charlotte rosetti ni
présentation signé michael almy
dorabella pour les législatives
sophie un petit peu de jeunesse un petit
peu de dynamisme
charles cros et tiny 31 ans est
officiellement candidate dans la
première circonscription des yvelines
nouvelle expérience pour cette
versailles et son mandat qui s'est
engagé politiquement pour lutter contre
le retour de nicolas sarkozy en 2015
après la question qu'on peut poser ses
mais pourquoi le parti socialiste parce
que j'ai toujours été socialiste j'ai
toujours voté à gauche c
le parti socialiste en fait représente
mes valeurs donc la justice sociale
l'écologie le partage et c'est vraiment
ça en fait qui mara qui m'a intéressée à
aller vers ce parti et puis c'est un
parti qui a une base militante qui est
importante et qui a engagé la première
circonscription un choix du coeur sur la
jeune socialiste qui a grandi et fait
ses études sur le territoire le
parachutage non merci je pense que je
pense qu'on va on va ceux-ci pas
possible pour comprendre ce qui se passe
dans un territoire il faut connaître il
faut les vivre
moi j'ai eu à versailles j'ai fait mes
études à montigny le bretonneux
donc pourquoi la première
circonscription parce que c'est chez moi
tout simplement
ses principaux axes de campagne
l'écologie avec notamment la défense de
la cause animale et la protection des
catégories défavorisées
c'est vraiment comment comment vous
aujourd'hui en tant que citoyen on peut
se réapproprier notre vie politique
comment on peut faire que tous ensemble
on puisse vraiment avancer et créer un
futur désirable c'était la petite phrase
de benoît c'est comme ça présenté son
programme aux électeurs charlotte
rossetti n'hésite pas à les rencontrer
sur les marchés et les brocantes savoir
comment il va l'être représenté 1
vous voyez pas le deviner donc si vous
n'allez pas à leur contact vous pouvez
pas savoir ce qu'ils veulent en tout
simplement c'est eux les ba censées eux
qu'on représente donc si vous n'allez
pas sur le terrain si vous n'êtes pas
leurs contacts ça pas vraiment grand
intérêt charlotte recettes il ne partira
pas favorite lors de cette élection
dernière présidentielle benoît hamon a
réalisé que 5,34 % des suffrages à
versailles est un peu moins de 10% à
montigny le bretonneux
la femme politique devra notamment
batailler contre la liste heller udi
mené par françois-xavier bellamy
remplaçant du député sortant françois de
mazières et le candidat de la république
en marche didier baichère cette liste de
candidats n'est pas encore définitive
nous continuons ce focus sur la première
circonscription qui couvre versa est lui
en cours à montigny le bretonneux avec
thibaut marshall bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous n'avez pas
la circonscription la plus évidente
montigny le bretonneux
manuel bacon qui fait un très bon score
sur versailles c'est françois fillon qui
était très largement en tête avec 44 45
% pourquoi cette circonscription pas
parce que je dis habite
est ce que vous aimez les défis j habite
y travaille je suis aussi je fais partie
des des 40% un peu moins des investis
par la france insoumise qui adhèrent un
parti politique et j'en suis responsable
et donc c'est aussi le rôle des
responsables de partis politiques
d'aller là où il faut aussi être
présents parce qu'on a des électeurs je
pense au quartier de jussieu je penserai
guyancourt je pense à beaucoup de
quartiers populaires montigny aussi on a
des électeurs qui ont envie de voter
pour notre programme et il faut qu'on
soit présent quel que soit le score
final avant de s'attarder
néanmoins sur la circonscription un mot
sur cette division à gauche pourquoi pas
d'accord par exemple avec le front de
gauche avec le parti communiste français
sont pénalisés
c'est compliqué ça peut nous pénaliser
effectivement et d'un autre côté pas
toujours parce que notre ligne a été
clair nous la france a soumis ce n'est
pas un parti politique ce n'est pas non
plus un cartel de partie il s'agit de
faire un rassemblement
on a proposé un cadre de rassemblement
avec une charte de rassemblement
plusieurs partis nous ont rejoints et
beaucoup de monde en kart et le parti
communiste n'était pas d'accord avec
certains points de cette charte est par
moments ils se sont rapprochés de nous
j'allais dire intelligemment et nous
aussi par d'autres moments c'était un
calcul de boutiquiers je te donne satire
conscription tu me donnes sept autres
épreuves accords initiaux nan mais sur
le terrain ce qu'on a entendu de la part
de candidats de la france insoumise de
la part des candidats du parti
communiste et nous on aurait bien aimé
s'entendre mais on va se retrouver à
leysin comprenez louis mais c'est la
même chose
j'allais dire c'est très difficile pour
nous c'est une élection pour nous
nationale le député il ne siège pas pour
représenter sa circonscription il est
élu dans sa circonscription mais ils
votent pour l'intérêt général et les
députés de la france et il prend des
décisions qui concernent toute la france
et donc le député il doit défendre un
programme il doit être cohérent et il
doit défendre aussi j'allais dire
quelque chose qui est intelligible pour
les lecteurs les lecteurs qui veut voter
communiste parce qu'ils aiment le parti
communiste il aime son programme et qui
voit que le parti communiste dans
d'autres départements est allié au parti
socialiste qui lui même
assume la politique du gouvernement
sortant c'est pas possible ça n'est pas
clair donc pour nous une clarté
on veut bien accueillir des communistes
et on en a des candidats communistes qui
sont présentés par la france a soumises
ils ont accepté de signer la charte est
pour eux clairement ils ne sont pas à
lié à aucun moment du parti socialiste
par exemple beaucoup estiment que jean
luc mélenchon a fait des erreurs depuis
le résultat du premier tour de la
présidentielle il n'y a pas eu d'appel
immédiat a voté pour le mouvement en
mars au front républicain face au front
national il ce parachute aussi du côté
de marseille et on lui reproche ce
tourisme électoral
vous en pensez quoi alors poule pour
l'appel du second tour jean luc
mélenchon a été contraint par le cadre
de la france est soumise la france
atomise il ne s'est pas fixé beaucoup de
règles puisque c'est un mouvement très
jeune mais dès octobre dernier nous
avons annoncé qu' il n'y aurait pas de
consigne pour le second tour et que les
militants seraient consultés donc il ne
pouvait pas donner de consignes ils n'en
avaient pas la légitimité ni
l'autorisation
les militants ont été consultés et
finalement ils étaient très partagés
donc c'était aussi son rôle en tant qu'
en tant que porte parole du mouvement
d'en garantir l'unité si lui s'étaient
positionnés pour un des trois camps
officiellement abstentions blancs ou
nuls ou votre mac row ils se seraient
automatiquement séparer des deux tiers
restant est donc il
il faut absolument qu'on reste unie pour
défendre l'intérêt des français du plus
grand nombre
ça veut dire ces mots que la dynamique
peut se poursuivre sur l'élection
législative sur son plancher par jean
luc mélenchon qui est un personnage
aussi qui a porté la des voix parce que
les électeurs se sont tournés vers lui
et pas forcément vers le mouvement mais
vers son personnage nous les candidats
de la france a soumis sont moins connus
ont fait le pari que les gens n'ont pas
voté que pour une personnalité mais pour
un programme qui s'appelle l'avenir en
commun et on fait le pari que les gens
est convaincu par notre porte parole qui
est brillant certes mais qu' ils vont
être convaincus aussi par les jeunes
candidats inconnus qui font un vrai
renouvellement contrairement à ce que
certains
tente de vous faire avaler avec des
vrais inconnu des vrais gens avec 6 % de
nos candidats qui sont agriculteurs par
exemple 94 % de nos candidats qui sont
sans mandat local électoral
donc voilà c'est un renouvellement mais
c'est toujours le même programme et
c'est ça aussi l'avenir en comme un ami
a évolué pour la législative a tué
législatives pas du tout ils sont très
minces contrairement aux autres on ne
cherche pas à faire du marketing
électoral
nous on est convaincu on l'a élaboré en
commun l'an dernier ce programme
l'avenir en commun il est basé sur
l'humain d'abord de 2012
réactualisé par plus de 3000
contributions en ligne par 12 auditions
de spécialistes etc etc c'est et des
apports des partis qui ont rejoint la
france a soumise ce programme c'est le
fruit d'un travail collectif et nous
cherchons à convaincre les électeurs que
c'est le meilleur
nous cherchons pas à quémander les voix
des électeurs en leur faisant plaisir en
retirant ceci ou retirant cela pour leur
faire plaisir
il s'agit de les convaincre que la
sortie du nucléaire par exemple est une
nécessité
vous avez parlé de de cet enjeu national
pour cette élection néanmoins même
question pour tous les candidats il faut
se faire élire dans une circonscription
coller à la réalité du terrain est ce
qu'il ya des propositions des choses
spécifiques sur lesquels vous allez
mettre l'accent pendant la campagne dans
la première circonscription
la première circonscription comme vous
l'avez dit c'est quand même un
territoire très particulier versailles
lui en cours avant la révolte
ce sont des villes relativement
dynamique
d'un point de vue économique mais aussi
avec quelques quelques quartiers
populaires nous on compte mettre
l'accent sur deux thématiques sur la
première circonscription
a priori on va beaucoup parler
d'écologie parce que pour nous c'est ce
qui manque beaucoup dans le programmes
des manuels macro et de la droite
et puis sur le social évidemment parce
que la loi les conneries xxl que et
qu'on nous promet c'est vraiment un
retour en arrière au 19e siècle où
l'ouvrier vend sa force de travail au
jour le jour et on est opposé à cela
sur cette première circonscription le
député sortant françois de mazières ne
sera pas candidat c'est françois xavier
bellamy l'un de ses adjoints à la mairie
de versailles qui va le représenter
investi par les républicains et par lui
dei
mais au moins votre regard sur le
travail du sortant sur le député sortant
très bonne question non mais il n'y a
pas de surprise c'est à dire que le
député sortant
c'est un député de droite qui votent à
droite il n'y a pas grand chose qui nous
qui nous rapproche
non je ne pensais pas l'adversaire ce
sera justement son successeur dans ce
scrutin
je crois que comme je l'aï dit mme ma
principale tâche est convaincre de
convaincre que mon programme que notre
programme l'avenir en commun est le
meilleur pour tous pour l'intérêt
général
donc c'est aussi de faire le plus gros
score possible pour aider à recomposer
une majorité de gauche
dans en cohabitation avec emmanuel
macron vous n'avez jamais été élu
c'était votre premier engagement cette
campagne de la présidentielle vous
poursuivez qu'est ce qui vous a poussé
pour que les électeurs je prenne un peu
mieux à rejoindre la france et insoumise
et aujourd'hui leur demander un mandat
de député
alors moi et comme je vous l'aï dit
j'étais responsable du parti de gauche
donc j'ai jamais été élu mais j'ai
participé à des campagnes soit en tant
que suppléant soit en tant que directeur
de campagne ou aider un petit peu moi
mon engagement politique il est basé sur
de grandes thématiques je suis
professeur de sciences économiques et
sociales et je dois avouer que
le capitalisme libéral que j'enseigne on
le sait tous il est il est plein de
limite et j'ai du mal à comprendre qu'on
continue à s'acharner à appliquer une
théorie qu'on connaît imparfaite et donc
je suis pour remettre l'économie au
service de l'humain et non l inverse
c'est la première motivation qui m'a
poussé à m'engager à gauche et puis pour
la suite il ya tout ce qui est écologie
réduction des inégalités c'est plus les
thématiques qui vont qui vont obliger à
sortir de mon confort personnel et
d'aller me battre
voyez sur les questions écologiques de
réduction des inégalités une dernière
question puisque l'actualité de ce
milieu de semaine c'est la nomination de
ce nouveau gouvernement vous avez
peut-être suivi gérard collomb à
l'intérieur nicolas hulot ministre de
l'écologie françois bayrou qu'on
retrouve garde des sceaux à la justice
bruno le maire à l'économie vous en
pensez quoi
c'est un gouvernement de droite voilà il
n'y a pas de surprise
emmanuel macron se prétendait libéral ni
de gauche ni de droite parce que sur le
plan économique qui était plutôt à
droite et sur le plan social plutôt à
gauche son premier ministre est
quelqu'un qui par exemple sur les lois
sur le mariage pour tous avaient une
position clairement de droite et non pas
libérale comme le prétend emmanuel
macron donc ce gouvernement avait
définitivement de droite
malgré la présence de personnalités
comme gérard collomb ancien militaire de
gauche c'est pas parce que gérard
collomb adhère au parti socialiste ou
adhérer au parti socialiste parce qu'on
sait plus après leur tambouille
finalement est ce que j'ai la carte ps
en marche
chacun s'arrange selon sa
circonscription non c'est pour moi c'est
pas une personnalité de gauche et moi je
suis un petit peu surpris et déçu par
par nicolas hulot qui en 2012 avait voté
jean luc mélenchon et je pense que il va
être très vite contrat avec un ministère
de l'économie
tenue par la droite il verra qui pourra
peut-être moins il un ministère d'état
ministère d'état on verra s'il peut
faire quelque chose sur notre dame des
landes sur le nucléaire sur les gaz de
schiste j'espère ce serait une bonne
nouvelle
merci thibault marshall je rappelle que
vous êtes candidat pour la france est
soumise dans cette 1re circonscription
des yvelines nous refermons le 7-8
politique prochaine édition le 24 mai la
campagne est aussi à suivre dans nos
différentes éditions du
chaque jour et puis tous les replays
sont à consulter sur notre site internet
et dante applications mobiles
[Musique]